the new topic boys is sink bank okay you
want people to send in pictures of your
tattoos videos videos of why you know
you got that tattoo and win and how
[ __ ] up you are ya brief videos brief
video brief you know documentary on your
[ __ ] tattoo on your ankle yeah but we
got our first submission boys and you
might recognize it iris about this I
have anxiety today
oh so you got the tip on this way guys
just got out of the shower - how much
time obviously I'm a very busy man but I
heard if I knew [ __ ] segments or
whatever it's called describe your
tattoo or whatever kind of catch you
think all that but anyway I figured I'd
be the first entry yeah I have tattoos
and I got him right here and I got these
by dr. woo who was a great artist and he
did this look if you tell him that eagle
that's because I got that tired eagle
joke that I have and my special of
Netflix man on fire and that's for the
man on fire and that's what I got and I
got them when I was 37 because I wanted
to get them because I wanted to I got
them at that age because I never want to
get them when I was younger because I
thought I would regret them much like
you guys definitely regret doing this
podcast together you absolutely do have
have to do this podcast now because of
the money you're not doing it because
you want to you're doing it because of
the money and that's fine but it's a
cash crop unlike my podcast
congratulations from this all to it
because it's straight from the soul I
hope you can repeat for a new hour so
whole so guys stop listening to the king
in this thing okay you know I can you
know how you can come on over you can
use this [ __ ] plane the King and the
sting this thing in the king I don't
even know what the [ __ ] it's called to
be honest
[Laughter]
first of all how did this goon okay
infiltrate our airway buddy dude this is
your buddy Brenda you time and L first
also on what you guys know that uh this
video submission was brought to you by
the cash app because you need the money
dude
well look Brandon this is you and uh
this is you and Brian's [ __ ] meal
ticket so the only two people sitting on
that plate on his armor you first of all
hated tattoos didn't eat remember that
he made fun of people with tattoos and
then he gets a bro gets a little money
in the bank bout a chain like a [ __ ]
like Gucci man he got tatted up not only
to get that up he did on his [ __ ] arm
on his wrist where everybody can see it
and somebody said it was hiding he had
like some type of a skin disorder or
something that it was hiding which is
something that I heard but I also could
have made that up kill him I'll use a
little just four men on that beard
either you know I'm saying maybe someone
brush in yeah we do anything too heavy
yeah I wouldn't go real dark you know um
that was so [ __ ] thank my Inc dude how
do you do it why does that on his arm so
we could easily sink it if it was flight
TWA 564 whatever when that one is what
about you guys over in Vietnam you guys
are taking down planes like nothing left
and right yeah you guys are like uh huh
your ears are hiding them huh yeah
no you flying over Iraq that's the knees
going to take down then blame it on
somebody else am i right yeah look at
this dude
sink my intro this is it there it's sink
it
speakers heat sink it Brendan this is
easy I'll give them this I'll give this
that dr. woo is amazing [ __ ] tattoos
who's dr. would was any good bro who
ain't good dude it's drawing all of it
looks like third semester [ __ ] heart
bro [ __ ] joy how did you get out of
New Orleans without any tattoos man with
the [ __ ] you've been through I have one
tattoo dude now never show it to you
really it's on your ass in it oh you
creep where's the back huh
I'm not telling how this told y'all
wasn't telling you would you'll have you
think I'm gonna forget that in just a
second yeah no I'm not dad
I can't believe you like that - yeah
mother effer I can't what it's offensive
though to some people that's why I can't
show it is it Confederate flag
no dude if I'm going offensive I'm going
Confederate flags a little bit of
laundry brah that's a little bit of pole
laundry dog I'm going offensive dude uh
look here's the thing about this tattoo
man
I've seen it 2,000 times bro this goal
aiming arm bro Nolan Ryan had that the
old [ __ ] hot arm bro that's nothing
also an eagle on fire you see a lot of
that down south at NASCAR events you see
it's on people's back a lot of Hell's
Angels yeah this seems like something
some little like thought gets over there
in Daytona yeah you right Daytona 500
standard tattoo yeah this is a yeah by
dr. Wu he thinks all flashy
sometimes I'll leave LA and realize your
tattoos each drives for Riverside and
get your ass beat breaking out that
[ __ ] yeah squid mistake yeah show up
in Ontario without your Harley with that
tattoo see what the [ __ ] happens yeah
you can't show up on a [ __ ] bird
scooter with that [ __ ] limp piece of
Van Gogh on your wrist
bro do you have a Harley of some assless
chaps you go down to [ __ ] Ontario
with that bird tip yeah get this guy out
of my podcast in his diary podcasted god
that was [ __ ] funny though yeah
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching